hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m.
Eastern you stupid
idiots I don't care and when you're in
Miami you won't care neither ow right on
my foot sorry this fake acting stuff
trying to be like the is so bad Jim it's
so every wacky every this happens in
every moment of their lives there's a
wacky thing that happens Jim stop you're
trying to do this is humiliating he's
trying to do early like e reaction it to
you know you're 20 years too
late 20 years too
old oh God that is such a dude he's with
like it's so you know what
[Music]
H I don't like Miami I don't it's not
like you know it's not like in in a
feminite little
twink decided to be a trans person like
Blair white or something right it's like
if if Dolph Lunden yeah just came out
was like I'm a woman now I'm living my
life as a woman and you'd be like you're
Ivan Drago [__] for Life fight this
nothing you're 6'4 you're not going to
[__] be a
chick I don't like Miami I don't feel
comfortable here this is ug [__] the
guitarist from metal
ocalypse yes oh man from the side you
can really see it as a dude oh yeah that
is a dude yeah a [__] David Bowie
from the front to side to back trust me
you can see it from every angle this is
a
dude and see you think on karaoke nights
they do a duet of dancing in the
[Music]
streets you don't need this music like
stupid music bed it's uh Tex text tur XJ
says seeing it's kind and makes me sad
was actually pretty funny with Patrice
on o Anda yeah we
know wow regular Marriott
wow that's like Liv the life Airport
Marriott we're going to Fleming's
restaurant oh because you're going on a
cruise to just staying there for the
Flemings wow another chain steak place
Coral Gable Coral Gable Flemings
Restaurant Miami Beach maybe we'll see
Miami mouth
there Adventures of Miami we have these
triangular tape concoctions to try to
stop I'm like
crazy but there's a lot of little sneaky
[__] they're doing with the camera to
try to play Down how much taller she is
no she's like oh yeah yeah
yeah do you notice that like they're
never like if you see them like walking
they're always like kind of far apart
and an angle or she's like or she's a
little behind them yeah exactly oh I
think she's been behind them a planning
yeah that
too those things they give you when you
you know what just hey Jim just get
Darby Allen shoes just get Rona Santa
boots those things where the the tube or
whatever the chemo will go into that's
what we look like we have these lumps
not my breast what
here I'm just teasing you I know hold on
I little don't don't film that I a
little itch in my nose it looks like I'm
digging but I'm not oh you look great
Jim by the way even in the car she's
like
slouching
yeah that's legs are all all underneath
the front seat of the
car didn't she also play
Vision Vision yeah she was like Paul
betney Paul betney reference yeah she
was like Paul betney Vision holy [__]
how far back is that one from Avengers
well no I know Avengers but which
Avengers I mean he played all of pretty
sure was he in all of them yeah he was a
voice for gold I sure did digging for
treats well I sure digged for gold I say
you didn't give me no no you think Kevin
spy oh I'm sorry response I'm digging I
heard you just said I dug for you still
doing that one
huh try it
again I've
been still doing that one too so funny
your
salad love you love you you stand right
here at Jim all
right I would also like I I said this on
nightwave right like if
I if I had a like a regular girlfriend
like one without a penis which I mean I
know boring I know Jim you mean a
girlfriend boring no but that's what I'm
saying if I just had a regular
girlfriend who was like hot whatever and
wanted to like hang around me all the
time and start filming [__] all the time
I would break up with them right she
black no they don't they're not always
black your fantasy they're not always
black but they are a lot no they're
usually white actually I like Jewish
isn't
white and neither is Italian so I'm
pretty [__] yeah I know um no but like
wouldn't it make you mis like just
imagine if your wife just
constantly was like we're going to film
another thing here and then we're going
to film another thing here while having
a sour to film real quick and when we
get back in the Uber and then we're
going to walk and film and we're going
to film and film and film and I can't
live like that like how many times we me
and Royce are both like we have a good
audience right we go to like these
places sometimes and we'll go live once
in a while right but we usually are like
look we'll go live for a little bit
we'll show everybody what's happening I
want to be doing this all night cuz you
want to you want to enjoy the moment
yeah yeah we're older so we're not used
to like the whole just holding phones up
everywhere and concerts and like it's
usually like hey I'm here I'm enjoying
this can I eat my [__]
salad okay okay what you what are you
doing everyone knows your trer we're
here in
Miami
yeah you're a guy you're a dude dude and
what are we doing embarrassing yourself
yeah there's more embar Jim Norton don't
got a special on Netflix or tuby or not
even freebie
[Laughter]
[__] filming Tik toks filming content
nobody cares um also you know this is so
this turned out this was the cam girl
that he was yeah yeah like years and
years ago obsessed this is a long weird
so I I'll give it to the [__] very
smart you cashed in on the biggest pay
Pig you had mhm yeah it's a good
point getting you all the content live
from [__] Miami look at these cars
does it look like does it really look
like I give a [__] [__] what does
that even
[Music]
mean I don't care and when you this is
so forced this person also has no
personality so forced yeah they're
training but no but I mean like you know
I mean I mean no Baseline personality at
all no wit no jokes and like also has
that weird like English as a second
language so it's almost like is this
what Norwegians think is funny you're in
Miami you won care neither ow right on
my foot
sorry you want to film now before we
leave let's do it real quick I don't
want don't even film the bed cuz I have
to think about what happened on it sit
next to each other cuz that's not going
to look like good footage but this is
real footage we don't need to all right
Nick you see how just your name my tits
are bulging out oh my God again I just I
couldn't I couldn't do the like I'm just
showing a picture like you you and your
wife going on a cruise and one of you
just at every single Moment Like of the
next thing you're doing going look all
right now that we're in the lobby
another film I know we just ate and
filmed and then we took a film in the
Uber and then we filmed in the street
real quick in the room let's go boom
filming again like can I just [__]
get ready for this cruise and enjoy
myself so what cruise was this B The
Bert Cruise The Bert crer Cruz bro oh
yeah chip chipperson we're milking
him what the [__] this chip chipperson
outfit I know what it is remember I know
what it is tell bad jokes and then
go which by the
way before he milked it to and beat it
to death it was podcast it needed its
own podcast but that's what I mean it
was a funny bit in the early days of it
when he would just completely like
derail everybody on a roll and steam you
know [__] sandbag everybody it was
funny once in a while and then it was
like every day and then it was like 10
times a day and then it was like you
just own podcast and then a GoFundMe for
Grand Jesus Christ it's just I'm on a
cruise ship huh great wow it's not fair
customer pays hey what's up sock ccka
party is
tonight
huh
huh okay
a I don't want to do this
anymore I don't even want to be around I
know I don't want to do that anymore
it's
enough